[Music]  we now go to our coronavirus coverage  and here is a look at the most recent  numbers test positivity rate now 3.5  percent  up one percent from yesterday 0.1  percent from yesterday  meanwhile 252 new cases have been added  and sadly five more deaths most coming  from here in clark county  a fourth coronavirus vaccine is in the  works in the u.s  doctors say the novavax vaccine could  help slow down coronavirus cases all  around the world  drug makers are expected to apply for  emergency use authorization in september  for this vaccine  but it won't be available until later  this year doctors say if the vaccine  becomes more widely available to  countries that are struggling with the  coronavirus  it'll help eliminate various strains  around the world